In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for July 20th, on which we commemorate the fiery ascension
into heaven of the Holy and Glorious Prophet Elias, the Tishbite.
The Holy and Glorious Prophet Elias, this angel in the flesh who received from God the
power to open and close the heavens, came from Tishbha in Gilead.
It is said that, at the moment of his birth, his father saw men dressed in white, wrap him
in swaddling clothes of flame, and, giving him his name, gave him fire to eat, the symbol
of the divine zeal that would devour him during his whole life.
From his childhood, he rigorously observed all the commandments of the law, and kept
himself permanently before the face of God in perfect virginity, constant fasting, and
ardent prayer, which rendered his soul as fire and made of him a prefiguration of monastic
life.
Ahab, having come to the throne in the northern kingdom, which had been in schism since the
time of Jeroboam, added to the impiety and depravity of his evil predecessors, encouraged by his
wife Jezebel, he persecuted the prophets and all those who remained faithful to God, and gave
himself up to the worship of false gods, Baal and Astadi.
The prophet Elias went to the king and declared to him, the Lord, the God of hosts, the God
of Israel lives, before whom I stand today.
No, there shall be neither dew nor rain during these years without a word from my mouth.
At the prophet's word, a terrible drought spread like a fever throughout the land, everything
became dried up, devastated, burned.
Men, women, children, domestic and wild animals all died through want of food.
The springs ran dry, the plants wilted, nothing escaped the scourge that God permitted in
the hope that the famine would bring the people of Israel to repentance and conversion.
At God's command, the prophet, who was clothed in sheepskin and a leather belt, left the kingdom
of Israel and went to the wadi kerith, situated beyond the Jordan.
He drank from the water of the wadi, and the Lord sent ravens to him, birds considered
impure by the Jews and infamous for their cruelty towards their progeny, to bring him bread
in the morning and meat in the evening, and by this act the Lord urged his prophet to mercy
towards the suffering people.
When the wadi began to dry up, God sent his servant to Zarifath of Sidon, making him observe
all along the root, the disastrous effects of the drought, calling him once again to compassion.
Elias came to the home of a poor pagan woman, who was gathering twigs to make a fire to
bake bread for herself and her son.
Despite the extreme necessity in which she found herself, she put the duty of hospitality
before all else, and, as soon as the prophet asked her, she prepared a cake for him with
a flower and oil that remained.
She received, without delay, the reward of her hospitality at the prophet's word, her
jar of flower and jug of oil did not become empty until the rains returned.
Elias had been staying in the widow's house for some days when her son died.
When the widow, in her anguish, accused the man of God of having brought misfortune on
her house, Elias took the child, carried him to the upper chamber in which he was lodging,
and having breathed three times on the inanimate body, calling upon the Lord with great cries,
he stored the young man alive to his mother, thus prophesying the resurrection of the dead.
The drought afflicted the land for more than three years, and a large part of the population
had already died, but God, respecting the vow of his prophet, did not wish to show his mercy
until Elias had understood that he desired not the death of sinners, but that they should repent.
He sent the prophet to King Ahab to announce to him that the scourge would soon cease.
Elias appeared before the king, who was stupified to see him approaching him freely, for the
king had searched everywhere for the prophet. Elias challenged him to gather all the people
of Israel on Mount Carmel, that he might witness the prophet's confrontation with the 450
prophets of Baal, and the 400 prophets of Asherah, who were supported by the infamous Jezebel.
When the great crowd was assembled, Elias said to the people,
how long will you go limping with two different opinions? If the Lord is God, follow Him, if Baal,
then follow Him. He asked for two bulls for the sacrifice to be placed on the wood, and the fire
left unlit, and he let the false prophets sacrifice first. These latter invoked Baal with great
cries, cutting themselves from dawn to dusk, but in vain. Elias mocked them, encouraging them to
cry more loudly, for fear that their God was asleep, or otherwise occupied.
When evening came, the prophet built an altar with twelve stones, representing the twelve
tribes of Israel, dug a large trench around the altar on which he had placed the bull, and commanded
that water be poured over the victim three times, so that the water filled the trench, and overflowed.
Then he uttered a great cry to heaven, invoking the God of Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob.
Fire immediately fell from heaven, and devoured the Holocaust, the wood, and the water.
The people, as one, fell on their faces, crying, truly, the Lord is the only God.
At Elias' command, they seized hold of the false prophets, and Elias killed them with his own hands
at the Wadi Kaishan. He then announced to Ahab that the drought was about to cease, while he himself
went up to the summit of Mount Carmel. He bowed himself upon the earth and put his face between his
knees, and his mind gathered in his heart, he began to pray. Seven times he sent his servant to
observe the horizon in the direction of the sea, and at the seventh time a little cloud appeared,
the sky was darkened, and rain fell in abundance, drenching the earth with heaven's blessing.
When Queen Jezebel learned of the massacre of her prophets, she became enraged and swore to avenge
herself. Elias, who had not feared the crowd of false prophets, was abandoned by the grace of God,
and overcome with fearfulness of heart, he fled to Bershiva in the territory of Judah.
Exhausted by his journey in the desert, he sat down under the shade of a tree and asked God
that he might die. An angel then appeared to him, bringing him a cake and a jar of water.
Sustained by this divine help, he was able to walk for forty days in the desert to
horrib, the mount of God. He entered into the hollow of the rock where Moses had in former times
hidden, and at night God spoke to him. Elias replied,
I am filled with fiery zeal for the Lord of hosts, for the children of Israel have abandoned
thine alters, and killed thy prophets, and I, I alone remain, and they seek to take my life.
God ordered him to go out from the cave and to stand on the mountain, for the Lord was to pass by.
There was a violent storm that split the mountains, and broke the rocks in pieces,
but the Lord was not in the storm, and after the storm, an earthquake, but the Lord was not in the
earthquake, and after the earthquake, a fire, but the Lord was not in the fire. After the fire,
the sound of a gentle breeze was heard. When he heard it, Elias wrapped his face in his mantle,
and went out and stood at the entrance of the cave, for God was in the gentle breeze.
The Lord told him that far from being the only just person alive, there were seven thousand
other Israelites who had not bent the knee to Baal. He was to retrace his steps and return to
anoint Hezel as king of Syria, and Jehu as king of Israel, and then to anoint Elisha as his own successor.
When he found Elisha occupied with plowing with twelve yoke of oxen, Elias threw his own mantle
over him, and made him his disciple. King Ahab continued to commit evil in pious acts,
and seized the vineyard of Nabuth, the Jesuilite, and had him killed, urged on by the evil councils
of Jezebel. The prophet Elias, who had remained in solitude for some time, was sent by the Lord to
Samaria, and said to the king, at the very place in which the dogs lapped the blood of Nabuth,
so the dogs will lap your own blood, and the prostitutes will wallow in it.
He added that misfortune would fall on the whole house of Ahab, and that the dogs would devour the body
of Jezebel within the bounds of Jezriel. At his words, the king was seized with compunction,
he tore his clothes and dressed himself in sackcloth, and began to observe a fast.
The Lord regarded his repentance with favor, and announced to him through his prophet,
that he would not give full reign to his anger until his son's reign.
Ahab died shortly afterwards, and his son Ahaziah, a superstitious man, succeeded him.
Falling ill, he sent messengers to seek an oracle from Balzabub at Ekran. The prophet Elias
presented himself before the messengers, and announced that the king would not live.
When they transmitted the message to the king, the latter, recognizing their description,
realized that it was Elias, and sent a troop of fifty men to arrest him. However, twice at the
prophet's injunction, fire fell from heaven and devoured the soldiers. On the third occasion,
the official begged Elias to spare them, and so he relented and appeared in person before the king,
announcing with his own voice that the ruler would perish because he had had recourse to false gods.
Ahaziah died a few days later, and his brother, Joram, became king of Israel.
During the twelve years of his reign, he suppressed the worship of Bal, but did not put an end to
the sin of Jeroboam, that had provoked the division of the people of God and had encouraged idolatry.
This is the reason that God brought misfortune on his house, and fulfilled the prophecy pronounced by
Elias during the reign of Ahab. Jahu seized power in a conspiracy against Joram, and entering the
town of Jesuil had Jezebel put to death. She was thrown from a high window. Her blood spattered the
walls of the town, and the dogs devoured her body before it could be buried.
After fifteen years of prophetic ministry, having fulfilled the mission God had given him,
Elias went from Gilgal to Bethel, accompanied by Alisha, who refused to leave his teacher.
From there, they went together to Jericho. Arriving at the Jordan, Elias took his sheepskin mantle,
rolled it up, and struck the waters, which divided to allow them to pass through on dry ground.
Alisha asked to receive a double portion of his teacher's prophetic spirit, to which Elias replied,
If you see me when I am taken into heaven, it will be granted to you.
While they were walking in the desert and conversing together, a chariot of fire,
drawn by fiery steeds appeared and separated them. Elias mounted into the chariot and was carried
as it were into heaven in a whirlwind, while Alisha cried out, Father, Father, the chariots of Israel
and its horsemen. He then seized the mantle of the prophet, which had fallen on him,
and striking the waters twice, was able to cross the Jordan, and was greeted by the sons of the prophets
who cried, the spirit of Elias rests on Alisha. Being thus lifted up on high in the body,
the prophet Elias prefigured the ascension of our Lord Jesus Christ, and by the descent of his mantle
on his disciple, he proclaimed the descent of the Holy Spirit on the day of Pentecost.
An eminent representative of the prophetic order who by his zeal arrived at the summit
of perfection, Elias was judged worthy to see the glory of God incarnate face to face in the
company of Moses and the three apostles on the day of the transfiguration, which prefigured the
second coming of our Lord Jesus Christ. Coming down from Taber, the disciples asked the Lord
if Elias was to come before the resurrection of the dead to reestablish all things as the prophets
had taught. Christ replied, Elias has already come, and they did not recognize him,
but treated him as they would, alluding to St John the Baptist, who had been sent to prepare his
coming with the spirit and power of Elias. As John was the precursor of the first coming in the flesh
of the Son of God, so Elias, we believe, will be the precursor of his second and glorious coming
at the end of time. Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ, our God,
have mercy on us and save us.